السؤال بالغ التعقيد طبعا عرفت لا يمكن
ببساطه عرفت الاجابه عليه ولكن الحد
الادنى من الاستجابه للكلام
السودان واحد من يعني
اللي انت تقول ممكن تقول عليهم بلد
ثقافيا هو بالغ التعقيد يعني عرفتها اللي
هو مالات هذا التعقيد ما نراه من عنف لاحق
يعني عرفت اللي هو الصراع الجوهر هو صراع
هويه
وهويه السودان يعني لا يكفي انك تقول
عليها انها متعدده ديفيروس
ولا يكفي انك تقول عليها فيها اختلاف مثل
ما علماء الاجتماع يفرقون بين تعدد وتنوع
واختلاف قال له هذا الخطاب اللاحق لمدارس
علم الاجتماع المعاصر يعني
[موسيقى]
الذاكره الثقافيه السودانيه
هي حقيقه تتميز بهذا الاختلاف يعني اختلاف
عنده ابعاد كثيره جدا جدا
الاستاذ يا استاذ مشاري انا دائما دائما
لما تيجي سيره
الهويه
والاختلاف وارتباط بالجغرافيا اسمها
السودان
اذكر قصيده لشاعر من فازوا بجائزه نوبد
القصيده بترجمه يمكن تكون مخله وفيها خفه
يعني لكن يقول انه تجري في في عروقي دماء
هولنديه ودماء بريطانيه ودماء زنجيه ودماء
هنديه هنديه بمعنى امريكا اللاتينيه
والسكان الاصليين يعني اما انني لا احد او
انني امه يا سلام ايضا السودان اذا
السودان بهذا المعنى هذا هو هذا هو عرفت
ومن هنا تاتي يعني اسطوره
اول اساطير المتراكمه حول هويه هذه
الجغرافيا السياسيه يعني خلينا نقول
بابعادها
الجغرافيه السياسيه
عندنا برضو شاعر برضو في نفس السياق يعني
اللي هو المرحوم الدكتور محمد عبد الحي
وهو كان من المهتمين بامر
الهويه يعني مهموم مشغول في خطابه
الشعر يعني عنده مقطع
الاكثر شيوعا دائما في الكتابات
المختلفه يعني
في في مقطع من القصيده
وكانه يخاطب احدهم يقول له
بدوي انت لا من بلاد الزنجي لا انا منكم
تائه عاده يغني بلسان
ويصلي بلسان